so speaking of which
let's talk about love yes which requires
to be
receptive of the world yes of strangers
i agreed
how do we put more love out there in the
world especially on the internet
one mechanism i have found to prove um
increased love and that's a word that
has many meanings and is you know used
in a very intense sense and it's used in
a very loose sense
can you try to define love sure love is
a strong sense of attraction
toward a another person entity
or place that causes one
to tend to react in a disproportionately
positive manner that's off the top of my
head disproportionately
yes so for example if you're not
proportionally
because like if you're someone's about
to
who you love is about to get harmed
you're moving heaven and earth
to make sure uh or like a book you love
you know like i love this book like
you're going through the fire to try to
save it
whereas if it's a book you really like
it's like oh i'll get another one it
i don't you know and a book's a kind of
a loose example but
so you're going with the love that's
like you're saving for just a few people
almost like romantically like love for a
close family but it's also
what about just love to even the broader
like the kind of love you can put out to
people on the internet which is like
just kindness sure i would say in that
case it's important to make them feel
uh seen and validated
and i try to do this when people who i
have come to know on the internet and
there's a lot
uh i try to do that as much as possible
because i don't
think it's valid how on social media and
i do this a lot myself but not towards
everyone
it's just there to be aggressive and
antagonistic
you should be antagonistic towards bad
people and that's fine
but at the same time there's lots of
great people and
especially with my audience and i would
bet disproportionately with yours
there's a lot of people who are because
of their psychology and intelligence
are going to be much more isolated
socially than they should
and if i and i've heard from many of
them and if i'm the person who makes
them feel oh
i'm not crazy it's everyone else around
me who is just basic
uh the fact that i can be that person
which i didn't have at their age
to me is incredibly reaffirming you mean
a source of love
but i mean love in the sense of like you
know you care about this person and you
want good things for them not in a kind
of romantic way but i mean you're using
in
a broad sense now yeah but you're also a
person who kind of
i mean uh attacks
this power structures in the world by
mocking them
yes effectively yes and uh
love i would say requires you to be
non-witty and simple and fragile
which i see it as like the opposite of
what trolls do
trolls are if i if there is
someone coming after what i love
there's two mechanisms right at least
two
i go up and i'm fighting them and in
which case
you bring in if you are getting hurt and
i fight even if you win the knife fight
or if you disarm them and you preclude
the possibility of a fight
and you drive them off or render them
powerless you
can you keep your person intact as
yourself
and you also protect your values so how
do you render them powerless
as you just said by mocking them one of
the most effective mechanisms for those
in power
we're much closer to brave new world
than 1984. the people who are dominant
and in power aren't there because of the
threat of you know the gulag or prison
they're there because of social
pressures look at the masks
i was on the subway not that long ago in
new york city
um no one cared who i was until i put
out the mask i was in the subway that
long in new york city
and i put this on my instagram i've told
this story before there was an asian
dude in his early 30s
he was like in western clothes it's not
like he had a rickshaw or something
an older man in his 50s stood up over
him on the subway
screamed at him said go back where you
came from
you're disgusting i'm gonna get sick if
you think this guy is a vector of
disease which is your prerogative why
are you coming close to him why are you
getting in his face
and what cause that was the rate sorry
so it was because
he was asian it was both it was
not having a mask gave him the
permission
to act like a despicable aggressive
person toward him right
and the point being uh a lot of these
mechanisms for social control
are outsourced to low-quality people
because this is their one chance to
assert dominance and status over
somebody else
so the best way to defuse that isn't
with weaponry or fighting
it's through mockery because all of a
sudden their claims to authority
are effectively destroyed so let me push
back on that what about
fighting that with with love
with um patience and like kindness
towards them i i don't think kindness is
i think that would be
a mismatch and inappropriate their
superman this batman
okay and superman's job is to help the
good people and batman's job is to hurt
the bad people
and i will always be on the batman side
than the superman side
both work uh silly tight costumes one
has
pointy ears both are ridiculous so it's
uh what's a billionaire who gets
you know he's swimming in trim which one
is the best batman
okay i'm i'm undereducated on um
okay on the superhero movies i apologize
okay but
but you're just saying you your
predisposition is to be on the batman
side is to uh fighting
the bad guys yeah of course that's what
i'm good at
that's what you're good at but just to
play devil's advocate or actually in
this case i am the devil because that's
what i usually
do watch the devil you're the angel's
advocate exactly
to be the to be the angel advocate yeah
it's like i
feel like mockery is um
is a is a path towards escalation of
conflict
yes in many ways yes so you're not
i mean it's kind of like guerrilla
warfare
i mean you're not going to win i
am winning we're all winning we're
winning on a daily this is my next book
we're winning
we've won before i'm not joking the net
the topic of the next book yes is the
white pill
the white pill is that we're going to we
are winning
the most horrible people are being
rendered into laughing stocks on a daily
basis on social media this is glorious
i so disagree with you i disagree with
you because there's side effects that
are
very destructive it feels like you're
you're winning but
we're completely destroying the
possibility of
having um like a cohesive society that's
called oncology
what's that mean curing cancer no i your
concept of a cohesive society
is in fact a a society based on
oppression
and not allowing individuals to live
their personal freedom
oh so your your utopian view of the
you're the utopian you're saying
cohesity society
i'm saying i don't need that i'm saying
there's going to be conflict right
there's going to be conflict
you and i are disagreeing right now
that's not cohesive doesn't mean we like
each other less doesn't mean we respect
each other less
cohesive doesn't it it's just a
euphemism for like everyone's submitting
to what i want
no i mean cohesive could could uh could
be that it could be
um it could be like enforced with
violence all that kind of stuff sort of
the uh the libertarian view of the world
but it could just be
being respectful and kind of each other
and kind towards each other and loving
towards each other
i mean that's what i mean by cohesive so
when people say free
it's it's funny like freedom is a funny
thing
because freedom can be painful to a lot
of people
it's it's all matters how you define it
how you implement it how it actually
looks like
sure and i'm just saying it feels like
the mockery of the powerful
leads to further and further the
divisions it's like
it's turning life into a game
to where it's always you're playing
you're creating these different little
tribes and groups
and you're constantly
uh fighting the groups that become a
little bit more powerful
by undercutting them through guerrilla
warfare kind of thing
and that's what the internet becomes is
everyone's just mocking each other
and then certain groups become more and
more powerful and then
they start fighting each other in into
basic they they form
groups of ideologies and they start
fighting each other in the internet
what the result is it doesn't feel like
the common humanity is highlighted it
doesn't feel like
that's a path of progress
now like when i say cohesive i don't
mean like
everybody has to be you know enforcing
equality all those kinds of ideas
i just mean like not being so divisive
that's like so it's going back to the
original question of like
how do we put more love out in the world
than the internet i i want divisiveness
oh you see you think this is that goal
it's very interesting it's the goal
so you we started this conversation with
you talking about you have love for that
small group
uh i think we both would agree to have a
bigger group be better especially if
that love comes from a sincere place
um i think our country specific i wrote
an article about this four years ago
that it's time to
dis-unite the states and to secede this
country has been held together with at
least two separate cultures
with thumbtacks and string for over 20
years uh there's an enormous amount of
contempt
from one group toward another this
contempt comes from sincere place
they do not share each other's values
there's absolutely no reason
just like any unhealthy relationship
where you can't say you know what it's
not working out
i want to go my own way and live my
happiness
and i genuinely want you to go your way
live your happiness if i'm wrong prove
me wrong
i'll learn from you and and take lessons
and vice versa
but the fact that we all have to be in
the same house together
is not coherent and that's not love that
is the path
towards friction and tension and
conflict
you